you always say that why you do so there  I told you  this is Chris Marlin over at JT Marlin  right now the whole firms going nuts  hold on let me open up the door to my  office give me the two thousand shares  there's a pleasure doing business but  sometimes the only way to stop evil is  not with good you must confront it with  another kind of evil oh the hell are you  [Applause]  my god  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  you stay  [Music]  No  well you what is it with you what do you  got a death wish or something that's  what it takes I just want to race I lose  you car  let's do it  your funeral rider died remember  [Applause]  [Music]  oh my god I [ __ ] knew let me not be  shame letting out Miami try and pull me  [Music]  the party  [Applause]  yeah let's cut him loose  [Music]